now the second move here I want to
consider is Knight to c3 which has a
merit of either playing f4 or Bishop to
f4 well please remember this whenever
your opponent plays Knight to c3 instead
of our last Bishop to b4 this time we
are going to play Bishop to c5 and it's
very very logical because you know
sooner or later the f4 is coming and it
in that instance this Bishop will be a
very strong on this diagonal so please
remember this whenever your opponent
plays nice to see 3 it's time to play
Bishop to c5 instead of Bishop to b4 and
here White has a to reply first reply is
the f4 straight away which has a merit
of attacking the knight in this instance
black has to play Knight to c6 and now
you can see all the dark squares up till
the g1 has been controlled by this
lovely picture
so here in one of my game my opponent
plays Bishop to c4 and I responded with
d6 and my opponent played over here
Knight to f3
I played Bishop to g4 which is kind of
provoking move because this bishop is
spinning that night so it's but obvious
response from the White is h3 and now we
are dropping this Bishop back to b6 and
the whole idea is we have weakened the
white skiing side so in his game my
opponent capture this bishop and after I
recaptured he plays Queen to e2 so idea
is very simple he wants to exchange my
good Bishop with his somewhat bad Bishop
so I played Knight to f6 and now indeed
Bishop to e3 came now Bishop e3 has a
two ideas not only it wants to exchange
the good dark square Bishop of the black
but if white wishes then white can goes
for the queenside castling and here I
played the strongest move of the game
which is Bishop to b4 it's amazing that
this one move and white is in dilemma
because if white goes queenside castle
now then I can simply snap up that night
so that's why my opponent needs to take
a timeout to defend that night so my
opponent plays Bishop back to d2 but
again that lost one tempo and I place
Queen to e7
and after he castle on the Queen side as
expected
I simply castle on the same side so I
cancel on the Queen side as well and now
my opponent plays a3 attacking my bishop
and probably he thought that I have to
drop my Bishop back but here comes a big
surprise to my opponent because I give
up that Bishop because I see this
amazing tactics so now White has to
forcefully capture with the bishop and
now comes Knight which fire now Knight
to h5 the two merits Knight can go to
the g3 square where it can folk who can
decree and the big merit is Knight is
attacking the loose ball on the f4 so in
the game my opponent defend the both the
threat with Queen to d2 but after rook
edge to f8 he realized that he cannot
protect that pole anymore
so in the game he decided to play fi but
after very simple equals fi e cross fi
andrew cross a fire he thought that he
can win a piece by g4 but he completely
overlooked that his own Knight is
hanging so in the game I simply capture
this night and after G cross h5
you can see black is emerged with a
clear pond up and not only that White
has a double pole on the edge file so
that is one game which illustrate how
you can play when you OP only play
Knight to c3 and f4
now in the second game instead of f4 my
opponent decided to play Bishop to f4
now when your opponent plays Bishop to
f4 there is always a good place for this
Knight which goes to the g6 which has a
merit of attacking that Bishop and
that's why Bishop has to drop back to
the g3 here the usual line continues
with the move d6
in this game my opponent plays Bishop to
c4 and I place Knight to f6 and now he
Dell off its last piece with Knight to
f3
I simply castle on the King side and he
did the same and now I place Bishop to
e6 again neutralizing the c4 bishop and
in this game my opponent decided to play
Bishop to b3 so it has an idea that if I
capture that Bishop then you can
recapture with the a pole and the a file
will be open up for his rocker so now
the less I continue with Queen to e7 and
now my opponent plays rook even so
protecting that pole and probably in the
future white can think of pushing that
pawn forward
so I played over here Knight to h5
attacking that bishop and now my
opponent responded with Knight to e4
counter attacking my vision but if you
calculate properly over here there is a
one sequence which is very good for the
black so I first of all capture this
bishop and my opponent captured my
bishop and now I simply capture that
night which at first glance looks very
awkward because you can see I have CC
pawns and after white recapture with the
H fall the whole idea of doubling the
pawned reveals because I place c4 so now
you can see that Bishop has only one
square left
and after Bishop to a4 I first of all
attack the white queen and when the
Queen goes to the e2 I simply play Queen
to b4 and now you can see that Bishop
doesn't have any Square to go so in the
game
my opponent tried b3 but after very
simple beef I my opponent plays a3 but I
can simply drop my Queen to the a file
and now that Bishop is a corner so that
is one game which highlight how you can
handle the positions when you open place
Knight to c3 and Bishop to f4
now the third move here which I want to
consider which is a very aggressive
reply by white which is a fall so
immediately attacking the knight and
grabbing the space here I recommend you
should play Knight to c6 and the whole
idea is to play Bishop to c5 and gain
access of all the dark squares now there
are many replies here for the wide but
if you opponent allow to play Bishop to
c5 then the black school is very good so
I am only considering the two options
which stopping black to play Bishop to
c5 and those are Bishop to c4 and Bishop
to e3 so let's see each by turn so first
option I'm considering is Bishop to c4
which indirectly is stopping Bishop to
c5 let's see what will happen if black
plays Bishop to c5 so if Bishop to c5
here then the very simple will be Bishop
cross f7 check and after King cross f7
white regain a piece with black King has
been displaced so please don't do that
please don't play Bishop to c5 when
you're open place
Bishop to c4 so instead of Bishop to c5
black has a stronger reply which is
Bishop to b4 check
and here again why it has a to reply if
your opponent plays Bishop to d2 then I
recommend you give this shack which
somewhat misplaced White King side pawn
so very obvious response of the white
will be g3 and now you play Queen to e7
so which has a merit of attacking the e4
the game which I have played in this
line my opponent responded with Queen to
f3 so defending that ball and I
responded with Knight to f6 or renewing
the threat and now there is no
satisfactory way to protect that Paul
except Bishop has to go back to the d3
so my opponent decided to push that one
here I played d6 so please note that
pawn is spin so I have using all sorts
of tactics to that poll and hear my
opponent plays Bishop to b4 so which has
merit of 2 pcs are attacking the knight
so I simply defer it with Bishop to d7
and now my opponent captured the space
shuttle
which leads to a position which is very
dodgy for white so after black
recaptures bishop white capture this
bishop and after night capture this
bishop you can see there are two threats
are looming so first is this pawn can be
captured and the second but the board of
this threat is Knight cross c2 so my
opponent has to defend that threat I
have one plays Knight to e3
but after that very simple will be D
cross Aoife and here my opponent castle
on the Queen side but here again I
castle on the Queen side and now you can
see again my knight can capture the a to
pawn and give a check so my opponent has
to defend that threat so my opponent
plays keen to be one but afterwards I
simply play E for and not only I have a
parcel on e5 but black clearly emerge
with a pawn up and finally I managed to
win this game so that is one sample line
which gives you an idea how you can play
against f4 and Bishop to d2
now after Bishop to b4 check 90% of the
time I give you guarantee your opponent
is going to play either Knight to D 2 or
C 3 and they both will be transposed to
each other so in this game my opponent
plays C 3 and after Bishop goes back to
the a5 my opponent plays Knight to f3
and now again we are back on the track
Bishop to b6 so again we are controlling
those dark squares and stopping y2
castle on the Kings side and hear my
opponent responded with Knight to g5 so
directly attacking the f7 which I
defended with Knight 26 and now he just
go for it so he plays Queen to h5 now
before Queen to h5 if you open and
greedily grab more space with the move
e5
then there is a very good reply which is
d6 and now if white capture that pawn
then there is a very good can beat idea
by black which is to castle on the Kings
side at this point and if you open again
greedily capture the fall then black has
this wonderful check which is rook to e8
and after various nature reply Bishop to
e2 and Queen cross c7 you can see not
only why it is stopped to castle on the
kingside but it will take an age to get
the species out of the file and castle
on the Queen side meanwhile black can
build up a serious attack on the center
so I recommend that whenever your
opponent plays ePHI you should certainly
play d6 and gambit the pole so in this
game after night to at six my upon
responded with Queen to h5 which has a
merit of attacking the f7 but I simply
castle on the King side and now hear my
opponent sacrifice to piece for rook and
upon so he played Bishop cross f7 and
after Luke cross f7 and nitro step 7 he
captured at night with my knight and now
my opponent plays Knight to d2
and I played Queen to e7 so which has a
matter of pressurizing the Ipoh my
opponents queen drop back to the f3 and
now I place defy so again taking
advantage of the fact that White King is
in the center
my opponent push forward so he played
efile and now I play Bishop to f5 please
note white cannot capture the D pole fo
3-ingredient the D pawn then after rook
to d8 let's say Queens goes to somewhere
let's say Queen to f3
we can play rook to d3 again attacking
the Queen and after Queen backs to the
base the Queen to d1 black has this
lethal check which is Queen to h4 and
afterwards white king will not survive
longer so that's why in the game my
opponent instead of capturing the D pawn
decided to play Knight to b3 and I
simply play rook to d8 and now my upper
in place Bishop to e3 so now this
planning is very simple he can go either
on the kingside castling or the
queenside castling
but I wonder if my opponent has seen my
next move that is very amazing and very
beautiful night sack which is night f
cross ePHI so please note this Knight is
attacking the Queen so wide respond is
pretty much forced so white place F
cross Z 5 but after variation Queen
cross Z fire that Bishop has been
attacked by two pieces so my opponent
has to forcefully go for this King lift
so my opponent plays King to f2 but
afterwards I place again amazing move
which is Bishop to g4 please note the
Queen cannot capture the bishop
otherwise Queen captures III and that
leads to disaster for Wyatt so in the
game my opponent decided to play Queen
to g3 trying to exchange the Queen's but
after very simple Bishop cross III the
white position is lost because if the
King goes to the f1 then after rook to
f8 check White King will not survive
long and in the game my opponent capture
this bishop but after again rook to FA
check my opponent realised that he lost
the Queen Queen to f3 but after very
simple Bishop cross F 3 and G cross F 3
you can see black has a queen against
the hook and I won very very easy
so that game illustrate how you can play
when you're poor in place f4 and c3 or
night and day too
now the second move which I want to
consider with stop Bishop to c5 which is
Bishop to e3 so you can see this move is
directly stopping Bishop to c5 but
nevertheless if Bishop to c5 as will
stop then we can always play Bishop to
b4 check and here where it has a two
genuine reply either c3 or Knight to d2
again they will transpose to each of
them so let's see why play c3 and here
we'll play Bishop to e5 and now at this
position White has a three genuinely
good reply which I have highlighted by
the arrows over here now if your
opponent plays Bishop to d3 then the
very simple will be the defy and now if
you open plays ePHI then the very simple
will be d4 so attacking a bishop the
very initial reply by the White will be
Bishop to D - so unpinning the c3 pawn
but afterwards we can play Bishop to b6
and you can see our Bishop has been
posted on a very nice diagonal also I
have highlighted where black PCs can be
placed so this will be a very easy game
for the black so that's why Bishop to d3
doesn't create any sorts of problem for
the black let's have a look at another
boo which is Knight to f3 and most of
the time if you reach this position you
will opponent play Knight to f3
against this I recommend you should play
Knight to f6 so attacking the pole and
here most likely opponent is going to
respond it with nine to d2 developing a
piece with defending the e pawn and now
we are going to play D Phi so renewing
the threat and now White has to
forcefully play e5 attacking the knight
and now we are going to play this Knight
to g4 so attacking the bishop now White
has a very tricky idea so I can play
Bishop to g1 so planning is very simple
white holes to play
s3 and when the knight moves away then
the bishop will come back to this
vertical space but here we can respond
Bishop to b6 attacking the bishop and
White has to capture this Bishop where
here will recapture with the a pawn and
now you can see black is threatening to
come to the III square so in this game
my opponent defend the threat with the
boom Queen to e2 and now I simply castle
on the King side and now as you expected
h3 came and now my knight drawbacks to
the at six and now my opponent decided
to play III so idea is very simple my
opponent wants to castle on the Queen
side so first of all I played route to
e4 which has a matter of attacking the
f4 so my opponent defended with the move
g3 and now I place
Knight to f5 so once again attacking the
g3 so my opponent defended with Queen to
f2 and now I place Queen to e7 it's
stopping any b3 movement by the white so
my opponent decided to castle on the
Queen side as expected but he completely
overlooked my next move which is route
cross a3
there is no point if white is not going
to capture that rope so my opponent grab
the rope and after queen cross 8 he
comes with the check my opponent plays
King to see to here I place very
accurate pool which is the move d4
attacking the c3 and now my opponent
played Knight to e4
so defending the c3 and I first of all
capture the c3 and after Knight
recaptures I give this check
so I played night to be four check and
after very natural king to d2 I give
another check so rook to DHS and after
king - II - I played Queen to be - check
here my opponent block the check with
the rook and I simply snap up that rook
and after Knight takes I simply snap up
the night and now you can see my thread
is very simple I want to play Knight
cross XIII and [ __ ] king and rook so
here I think my opponent was in time
trouble
so that's why he stopped this thread by
Queen to f3 but that will [ __ ] the king
and a queen so Knight to d4 and the
queen is a goner
even though let's say my opponent
doesn't fall for that
the blacks position is very very
wonderful so that is how you can play if
your opponent responded with Bishop to
e3 c3 and Knight to f3
now the third move white can play here
is Bishop to c4 and against this I
recommend you should play Queen to e7 so
attacking the epon and the very natural
way to defend this pawn is true knight
to d2 where we can play this move which
is d6 and in this game my opponent
decided to quickly go for the queenside
castle because he think that he has a
space advantage on the kingside so he
played Queen to f3 and here I responded
with Knight to f6 so idea is very simple
if he would go to the queenside castling
that I can play Bishop to g4 and grab
the exchange of course my opponent has
to stop that
so Oberon plays s3 and now I Castle on
the Kings side and here he plays Knight
to e2 developing a last piece and now I
played rook to e8 so you can see now
three pieces are pressurizing the a pawn
so in the game my opponent decided to
play Knight to g3 so defending one more
time and now I simply place V Phi
attacking the bishop please note that
pawn cannot move otherwise Bishop will
fall so that's why in the game my
opponent defended the pawn with Bishop
to d3
but after very simple Mike Rossi for and
Knight cross c4 I place this very good
move which is f5 so you can see that
night is going nowhere in the game my
opponent decided to play Queen to e2 so
getting off from that f3 square but I
simply capture denied with the f4 and
after Bishop to b4 which has a matter of
painting tonight I simply place
to h4 so again attacking tonight which
my opponent defended with Queen to f2
but now comes a big surprise which is
defy so now that Bishop has been
attacked and if the bishop moves then
the e pawn will go forward so in the
game my opponent capture the pole but
after I launch a vigorous attack with
nitrous Tafolla so please note my roof
is hanging and in the game my opponent
greedily captured the stroke but
afterwards I simply play III and you can
see white position is almost lost not
only black will regain to piece for a
row but black has a throne in white scam
which is this monster III pawn and that
helped me to win the game so that is how
you can respond it if you open in place
Bishop to e3 c3 and Bishop to c4
now forth and the last move which I want
to consider is Bishop to f4 so attacking
the knight please remember this whenever
this Knight is a tagged by the bishop
you need to play Knight to g6 and
counter attacking the bishop and most of
the time Bishop will drop back to the g6
and now you can play Knight to f6 so
which has a merit of attacking the a
pawn please note if you open place
Knight to c3 then you can pin that night
with Bishop to p4 and the resulting
position will be very much favorable to
the black so in this game my opponent
responded with Knight to d2 and here I
responded with Bishop to c5 and now he
plays Bishop to c4 and I simply castle
on the Kings side now a normal player
will play Knight to f3 in this position
and probably go for the King side
castling but to your surprise Knight to
f3 it's not possible at this point
why here comes white so if you are one
plays Knight we have three
and you can simply play D Phi and that
attacks through peace and if Bishop
captures the night captures and the
position remains the same so most likely
the operator is going to capture with
the pawn but afterwards rook to e8
creates a great nasty threats for the
wipe so at this position Knight G to F 3
is not at all good for the white so in
this game my opponent decided to play
Queen to f3 so idea is very simple
my opponent want to go to the queenside
castling but I responded with rook to e8
and after very initial queenside
castling I responded with the mu D Phi
please note my idea is very simple I
want to play Bishop to g4 and gain the
exchange so my opponent spot that and he
played Bishop to e2 and now I simply
played Bishop to e6 so protecting the D
pawn and now hear my opponent responded
with
h4 it's very obvious because when the
opposite side castle is there both the
side will go for the flight attack after
some calculation I decided to play Queen
to e7 and meeting h4 with the D cross e
4 so right now
why doesn't have any time to capture the
night because his queen has been
attacked and in the game my opponent
capture that pawn afterwards I captured
an ID with my f6 line at first sight it
looks very suicidal because can't white
can simply step up that night but that
is exactly what I was hoping for because
after H cross g6 I simply played Queen
check and after very nature looking
Bishop to a full I simply snap up that
pole so after all this tactics black
defended the piece and regain upon hear
my opponent decided to play Knight to h3
and this is a critical mistake because
here I simply snap off that light and
after very nature looking rook cross h3
I simply played Knight cross f2
and you can see that [ __ ] two rooks
so in the game my opponent plays rook to
g3 probably he was relying on this
tactics that he can save his rooks but
after blacks next move he realized that
what kind of danger he is in so I played
queen to e6 now there are two threats so
black can capture this bishop and also
Black Knight can capture the rope so the
only force reply left is to route to
even afterwards I place rook to d8 look
to D it doesn't look like a very
attacking move but in fact it has a big
venom inside after very nature looking
White's reply rook to g5 which has a
merit of attacking my loose bishop I
wonder if you can spot the amazing move
by black I give you a few seconds try to
find a very good move by black and the
move is BAM Queen Crossy - please note
this Queen has captured of piece and not
only that is trying to capture the other
rook with checkmate threat in the game
my opponent capture the screen with his
own Queen but after rook cross e - my
opponent cannot capture this rope
because at the end mate is threatened so
in the game my opponent decided to take
away his rook from the firing line so he
played rook to have fun but after Knight
to e4 I defend it not only my bishop but
it also attacked the rope
and after all this black emerge with a
clear piece up and here my upon design
so that is one entertaining game in
Bishop to f4 line which will highlight
how you can play for the win as a black
position after watching all my games I
can confidently say that none of the
fights reply after D cross e5 and night
cross ePHI creates any kind of serious
problem to the black black can always
look out the theory which I have
recommended in this video get a good
position out of it as a black you should
be very happy when your opponent plays D
cross E Phi because that allow you to
equalize early in the game